hey lloyd
yeah i immediately don't like you
well i'm glad we're on the same page
the gray man expanding into this major
spy franchise i know ryan's doing
another one so that's going to be great
yeah they did talk to me about doing
something with lloyd i gotta have a
better understanding of what that is but
uh but yeah i'd be excited it was a fun
character to play
we wouldn't mind some more of lloyd and
his trash stash either and chris's dog
dodger who was right by his dad's side
our entire interview would love to get
back on set how does dodger handle the
bright lights of hollywood he's a social
butterfly he loves being on set it's
like his favorite thing because everyone
loves him yeah he's a he's a real good
set mascot
now how does dodger feel about you being
quote laser focused on finding a
long-term partner
i haven't asked him i'm not quite sure
right now he's been my long-term partner
have you tried the dog park chris
uh yeah he's he's you gotta be careful
saying that right now those words
literally he'll he'll start bouncing off
the walls typically i spell those words
out in interviews my bad i almost caused
chaos over here how does dodger feel
about sharing your love
um
he's pretty good he gets protective if i
give love to other dogs for the most
part he's i mean he loves everybody
[Music]
do you think that being a dog dad has
kind of prepared you for
fatherhood one day i guess it's a good
prep course but but i would imagine
anyone who has kids would say
you haven't seen anything yet does
dodger do well around children
oh yeah he's great he's great around
kids very curious very loving very sweet
he really understands you know you can
see him understand that he has to
be a little more gentle
good boy all right
are there treats on deck over there how
much does dodger love jigs he really
does i mean that was part of the reason
i was excited to do this partnership but
you know he had loved the treats for a
while you know it's just nice when you
can partner up with people that have
shared passions and and kind of a
similar love you know they're all
they're all rescue dog owners themselves
and on top of it the product is just so
good
[Music]
you